how do you succeed in doing videos on
things you know are passionate if
somebody else is already in and
succeeding at it nobody else is winning
is coming out of yours if that was true
the game was over a long time ago that's
right why did LeBron try
and control time leading scorer why is
Kevin Hart doing that Eddie Murphy did
that already but why did Eddie Murphy do
that Richard Pryor already did yeah what
are we talking about here excuses like
that are just people that are scared to
do the thing and fail on Merit they feel
better that somebody already took it the
world is abundant if you're good enough
no matter how much is already taken you
can get yours too I wasn't the first
person to talk about kindness I was the
first person to talk about work I wasn't
the first person to talk about
technology that is a ludicrous point of
view and I come from a place of
compassion when I use that statement
that person needs to realize that's a
subconscious excuse to not do yeah and
it's better to blame that oh they didn't
get lucky somebody already did it versus
them having to put in the work to do